dr nash in total transformation who is
sponsoring this next segment have been
transforming lives all across the valley
and for dominic it's more than weight
loss take a look working with dr nash i
lost 70 pounds in three and a half
months and reversed my type 2 diabetes
and i feel great dr nash dominic's
transformation is unbelievable it's
amazing what you've done with dominic
tell us more about the guy
yeah so dominic was somebody that found
out that he was pre-diabetic when he was
20 years old he worked for five years
trying to figure out through his own
methods uh what to do about it how to
lose some weight and turn it around and
ended up becoming full-blown diabetic by
the age of 25 and that's when he decided
to get serious and do something that's
when he found me he lost a hundred
pounds by the using my program and
reversed the diabetes in three months
how come how come some doctors they can
they can manage these symptoms but
you're making these drastic changes for
people how you doing this so
unfortunately doctors hands are really
tied when it comes to diabetes because
they can really only use medication and
as the disease progresses and worsens
they'll add insulin uh to the equation
and while those measures will work on
controlling things like blood sugar the
disease and the disastrous symptoms will
continue to worsen and the problem is i
don't think people understand just how
bad the symptoms get we're talking
blindness amputation heart disease
kidney and liver damage and now severe
to fatal outcomes with covid19 on top
of this stubborn weight problem this
obesity that just won't go away
your cat has arrived to join our
interview today i love it when your cat
shows up
that's just great i know so he
photobombed my shot with you jason it's
fantastic let's talk about these
let's talk about the five metabolic
factors that that you have
right so one of the things that i found
out after my 25 year struggle with
obesity is that for me personally it was
the damage that was driving the weight
problem not the calories and exercise so
those five things are the total in the
total transformation so one is going to
be toxicity the other one is going to be
overfed but undernourished not getting
the proper nutrition to turn the
metabolism around the next one is going
to be the retraining of the hypothalamus
or the set point that tells your body to
stay at a certain weight the a is for
acidity also known as inflammation which
drives stubborn weight to the belly and
then l is the lower the imbalanced
hormones up to seven different hormones
that if they are not in the proper
position in that body you literally
can't burn body fat and every week you
come on the show you kind of special for
us what do you have for us today oh you
know i do so
normally when people come and talk to me
when they go online and do the
evaluation it's 97
to do that but when las vegas now allows
me to talk with jc about this topic that
i'm so passionate about i have 10 spots
available where we will do that online
evaluation for 9.97 you want to go to
the website to secure that spot if you
call my office they don't know about the
special they're going to try to charge
you 97
so go to that doctornash.com forward
slash eval those spots go quickly and
make sure that i get a chance to talk to
you and get you the help that you need
to get well
thank you to total transformation for
sponsoring this segment visit
eval drnash.com take advantage of her
special offer las vegas now we will be
right back